have you tried using this on your face
not yet okay good did you ever feel the
urge to yes why because i like
destroying my face
hi this is omar from lab muffin beauty
science i'm not a phd in chemistry i am
not a skincare nerd and apparently some
of you might be horrified by my old
skincare routine i'm sure many of you
might have someone in your life like a
partner your mum your dad your sister
your brother who just has the worst
skincare routine
and i mean a lot of people are
genetically blessed and generally
they're fine with a frankly trash hot
skincare routine but sometimes there is
just some things that just don't quite
sit well with your spirit
they kind of mess up your chakras
your aura gets a bit tainted so today i
thought i'd talk about some products
that might help ease them into good skin
care habits that don't destroy your
faith in all that is good and holy this
video is sponsored by necessary and the
reason i came up with this idea is
because this is actually the one product
that's in both our showers and it's sort
of like the product that got him out of
this awful routine i've eased him into a
bunch of other products as well there's
another necessary product in there but
first
let's talk about what you used to do
so six months ago my skincare routine
was quite literally just this and
tresemme shampoo
i used to use the shampoo not just on my
hair but all over my body when i ran out
of the soap and
um used to use the soap on my armpits my
back my face
just hot swapping really whatever i had
available hot swapping hot swapping
so omar is a bit of a hard sell when it
comes to skin care because he doesn't
really have many major skin problems and
when he does get a pimple he actually
enjoys digging it out
yep
so i found what works for omar is a good
gimmick
yep utility packaging
and minimal skin feel afterwards
absolutely so obviously the first thing
we had to fix was the soap and shampoo
on your face
what was wrong with that
so let's start with the soap
the reason i went for the necessary body
wash is because it is pretty much
formulated like a face product so this
has the utility packaging which omar
loves it has a screw top the top doesn't
come off and so you don't drop it it's
very easy to use for a bottle product
especially in the shower this
twisty twisty top should be included in
all products love this this has a pretty
nice scent it's unisex it's light it
leaves your skin pretty moisturized
unlike the bar soap if you want to stock
up on more of these magical twist tops
you can use the code lab muffin 10 for
10 percent off necessary okay so bar
soap
for those of you who
don't know
is made of really long surfactants so
surfactants are the molecules that clean
your skin they have an end that lacks
water and an end that likes oil so if
you have the two of them in the one
package the oily end latches onto the
oil and your skin and then the watery
end helps the oil dissolve into water
the problem with soap is that its
surfactants are really long and narrow
and that means they get into your skin a
lot more easily and they irritate and
they also have a charged head which also
adds to the irritation so out of all of
the
surfactants that are commonly in
skincare products bar soaps have the
worst in terms of irritation and dryness
another reason biosoap is bad is because
it tends to have a really high ph now on
your body that tends to be okay because
your body has thicker skin some parts of
your body also has a higher ph so
armpits for example in groin actually
have higher ph which means that soap
isn't quite as bad but on your face this
is one of those things that can lead to
more acne your face likes to be at a low
ph at a higher ph acne bacteria actually
grow better you're thinking about
squeezing pimples now aren't you yep
so that's why we don't like bar soap on
our faces
now shampoo is depends on the shampoo
sometimes they're actually okay for your
face shampoos typically have a higher
concentration of surfactants because
your hair has a higher surface area than
your face the more concentrated it is
the more cleaning power it has and so
shampoos are kind of like really
concentrated cleanses so can i talk
about why i started using shampoo go on
so i grew up thinking that i should be
shampooing my hair every time i had a
shower
and around the age of 13 i started
needing more than one shower per day
because i have a shower in the morning
and a shower in the afternoon after
playing sports so i'd be showering twice
a day
occasionally i run out of soap i'd run a
body wash and you know i ended up using
shampoo on the rest of my body and at
one point i put on my face and it felt
amazing what do you mean by amazing dry
so there's another problem we have omar
likes that dry type feeling and a lot of
people do because they don't realize
what it means is that your skin is
getting warped feels clean
skin's getting warped okay so the dry
type feeling is actually surfactants
going in and messing up the shape of the
proteins in your skin when they change
shape that's what gives the tight
feeling and
as you can imagine proteins changing
shape on your skin is not a good thing
for your skin right so this has
surfactants that are commonly found in
face products as well which is why i'm
comfortable giving this to oma because
he can use it on his face and it's not
that bad um in fact it's actually fine
so on top of having nice gentle
surfactants this also has glycerin which
is hydrating it also has niacinamide so
we're sneaking some actives into his
routine as well and so hopefully this
leaves your skin feeling hydrated and
not tight
even though you like the tight feeling
but you'll get used to not having the
tight feeling i promise okay so onto
omar's pimples this is the main pimple
treatment you were using before yes
this
this is good show me what you did to
your pimp show it show the class what
you did to your pimples
before before um
i feel like i'm about to get
i feel i'm about to get made fun of here
all right so here is a mole um show us
how you would squeeze that so what i
would do is i'll take these tweezers and
i just put that on the other side of
each side of the pimple and then push
and then slightly squeeze and it pops
right up slightly squeeze
slightly squeeze for me
you were putting your hold back into it
i've seen you a little bit of blood
doesn't really affect much so obviously
we needed to make sure oma didn't get
pimples and that's why we introduced
the necessary scrub
and
an exfoliating towel so this
this i love i've got oily skin and i get
pimples on my back all the time and it's
hard to reach and this made a massive
difference feels nice i feel soft
afterwards i use it weekly
i've got a weekly routine you do my one
complaint
is where's the twisty top
come on where's the twisty top
this is like a screw top
twisted top would be nice
so i think the reason they don't have
the twisty top is because this scrub
this actually contains particles this
has bamboo charcoal and pumice and so
the little bits might actually get stuck
in the twisty top i assume that's why so
originally i tried to make him use a
leave-on chemical exfoliant especially
on his back
no no i tried to get him to use the
poreless choice bha which is one of my
favorites for my face um he doesn't like
it why not no feels like imagine putting
vinegar or soy sauce on your skin it
just turns sticky and
who'd want that
people who like clear skin
just feels off and weird so yeah skin
care favorite for us um apparently just
doesn't work with some people
um i also gave them the spray version
and again like even though that was more
convenient it was still sticky
yeah
i also tried this which you were
actually okay with
yeah but you have to do it right yeah so
the dr dennis gross peels um the nice
thing about these they are really
expensive though the nice thing about
them is you can sort of get a whole
bunch of uses out of one so one of these
is enough to do both our faces and both
our backs it's also a lot less sticky
than the polish choice version i think
the stridex pads are also quite
non-sticky as well so that might also be
an option but again it's a little bit
harder to get to your back whereas if
you have a scrub combined with an
exfoliating towel
then your person can do their back
themselves
so another nice option i think for
people who tend to use their body
products on their face is the dove cream
beauty bar so this looks like a soap but
it's not actually a soap they use um
surfactants that aren't
soap surfactants and they it has a lower
ph so a lot of soaps um those
surfactants only work at higher ph so
this has the deathless effectors and the
lower ph so this makes it fine for your
face one of the issues some people say
is that it breaks them up because of the
creamy ingredients um but if it doesn't
break you out then this is actually one
of the few bar soap looking products you
can use on your face without worrying so
this is another product i gave to oma
it's the fenty cleanser and this is
actually the only cleanser he uses
because what do you like most about it
that twisty top
so this is my actual bottle that i'm
using in
the shower
um so it's still a bit wet so what i
like about this
product is that this is a goods twisty
top
made a massive difference in my skin
makes my skin makes my face feel amazing
especially compared to soap yes
um less breakouts and
compared to shampoo this is way better
why is it better
because it's less aggressive
little bubbles little bubbles oh bubbles
do you like the bubbles i like the
bubbles i also like the foaminess of
this um it does foam up very nicely on
my skin makes me feel like i'm cleaning
my skin now on to sun projection now one
of the reasons i didn't give oma a
chemical exfoliant even though that is
often recommended for beginners is
because he doesn't wear daily sunscreen
and one of the things with telling
people to use chemical exfoliants
without daily sunscreen is that it often
ends badly it's so much harder to start
someone on a sunscreen than it is to
start someone on a chemical exfoliant
now on to your sun protection this was
your sunscreen
tell me when you used it
right so i used this when the uv rating
was higher than 10 and i was going out
to the for a long walk or i was going to
the beach and gonna go swimming so i
typically only use this on my face if i
was going on a walk um and if i was at
the beach and taking on my shirt and
going into the water then i'd use this
all over my body
so what was stopping you from using this
more regularly because you go on walks a
lot yeah it's mainly because
i'm mainly trying to prevent myself from
being sunburned on my face so that was
the main reason um
besides that it's really sticky
not very nice texture on my skin or on
my hands i hate it on my hands
um that's it so being a sunscreen
hoarder i gave omar a whole bunch of
sunscreens that he could try out
tell me what you thought of each of
these
this i didn't like i don't like most of
my skin i don't like that feeling of
putting like
whipped cream on
on a surface and trying to spread it
around it's so awkward i don't like this
and
the cap now
utility is a big thing for me don't like
it
yeah so i actually thought oh my would
like this because it's long lasting it
sinks into your skin and after it's
sunken on you can actually wash your
skin with a bit of water and it's still
fine but apparently the film that's left
on your skin afterwards still was too
much it does leave a little bit of a
film because that's how it stays for so
long no hate it as clear
smells like
something is on fire when it shouldn't
be
it also leaves a residue on my skin
don't like that and
what's with the flip cup you know if i
put this in my backpack it's going to
explode everywhere
now don't like it
so as much as we like to think everyone
is fine with fragrance free a lot of
people are not
and yeah
these are all things that i never even
thought of considering when it came to
recommending your sunscreen so
interesting data collection by all right
now i like this one uh i this is the
second from the top for me um it's
really it's really nice and uh
light on my skin
it gives me spf 50 which is really good
50 plus 50 plus
has a twist top which is okay pretty
good won't be worried about exploding my
backpack um and smells nice so this i
would use but it's not my favorite this
however is my favorite and this is la
roche-posay this one it meets all the
marks of my favorite sunscreen because
uh it's nice and thin
uh light doesn't leave a residue doesn't
and it smells nice
um actually does its job with protecting
my skin and the utility
okay so it's not the twisty thing that
you know necessarily has but nice screw
top here i'm not afraid of it exploding
my backpack this this is the goods so
how do you feel with your new routine
i have a weekly routine do you feel like
a changed man i feel like i
actually care about my skin
and this is weird so my skin has gotten
better i have a weekly routine now and
my skin's gotten better
how's it going better
less pimples
and you know less dryness less
everything it's just normal skin
which is basically what i want i don't
really care about pigmentation don't
really care about you know
scabs or anything else like that i don't
really care but it's gotten better it's
less annoying
that's me
so i feel like that is a win
high five high five
yeah this is omar's routine
before and this is omar's routine after
bio by ori la roche per se la roche
posay oh my gosh i don't really like
moose
mouse moose what's this called again